if you believe that what you're doing is
right then you have to stick with it you
have to stick to your guns you can't let
other people tell you that what you're
doing is wrong and be persuaded by them
otherwise you're never going to be able
to build the business or the life that
you deserve hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and Warren Buffett likes to
say that people are neither right or
wrong because other people agree with
you you're right because your facts are
right and your reasoning is right and it
doesn't matter what other people think
and it's true as an entrepreneur you are
going to have to make decisions that
other people won't understand you're
going to have critics people going to
tell you it's a stupid idea you
shouldn't do this you should take the
safe route you should go get a job what
you're doing is crazy and often it's
going to come from people closest to you
it could be your friends it could be
your family it could even be trusted
business advisors but if what you feel
you're doing is right you have to keep
going you've got to play it through
until you feel like it's not right
anymore if you let other people dictate
what you should and should not do then
you're never going to be able to build
the business that you deserve and have
the life that you deserve so stick to
your guns if you feel it's right if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below I'd also love to hear what you
have to think if you don't leave a
comment or the video or if you have a
question feel free to leave in the
comments underneath I always read those
loves him to come in thank you and I'll
see you soon